Hi, Bob the Canadian here.
It's been a while But I'm back to make videos to help you learn English once again If you're wondering why I'm wearing sunglasses, it's because it's sunny and it's quite snowy out here in Canada And that
makes it really hard to see and to keep my eyes open so nothing wrong with my eyes But I'm gonna wear sunglasses for this video.
Well since I've been gone for a while I thought a great topic for a video would be some phrases that you could use to greet someone when you haven't seen them for a while.
And I did a video about this earlier, I think I went over four, I'll put a link up here for you, four things that you could say when you haven't seen someone for a while.
In that video I looked at the phrases, long time no see, it's been a while, it's good to see you and how have you been.
So if you want to watch that video as a review, you could do that.
But in this video I'm going to look at five more phrases, five more things that you can say when you haven't seen anybody for a while.
Hey welcome to this video.
If this is your first time here, don't forget to click the subscribe button below and give me a thumbs up if this video helps you learn English.
So we haven't seen each other for a while and you might be wondering what kinds of things can you say when you haven't seen someone for a long time.
So in this video let's look at five phrases.
Let's look at five English phrases that you can use when you haven't seen someone for a long time.
Let's start with the first one.
It's really simple.
Imagine that your mom or someone in your family has been gone on a trip and you're picking them up at the airport.
The very first thing that you would say to them is welcome back.
You would just say welcome back because you want them to know that while they were gone you were thinking about them and that now they have returned they are welcome to be back in your country and to be
back in your city.
So the first phrase that you could use when you see someone after they've been gone for a while is welcome back.
A second phrase that you could use if you haven't seen someone for a a long time is to simply say, I missed you.
And if you're speaking on behalf of other people, maybe you're speaking on behalf of your family or as a boss at a workplace, you could say, we missed you.
And in English, when we say, I missed you, it's from the bottom of your heart.
If you haven't seen someone for maybe three or four months and then they finally come back to visit or come back to your hometown town and you would just say, I really missed you.
I missed you.
And that just lets them know
that while they were gone, you were thinking about them, that while they were gone, you were actually spending time each day thinking, I hope they're okay, I hope they're having a good time, etc.
So excellent thing to say when someone comes back is, I missed you, or we missed you, if you're speaking on behalf of other people.
A third thing you could say to someone that you haven't seen for a while is just I'm glad you're back or we're glad you're back just expressing to them that while they were gone you were sad but
now that they're back you are happy or glad so you could say oh I'm so glad you're back I'm so happy you're back we're so happy that you're back and that would be just be another a really warm and friendly way
to greet someone that you haven't seen for a while.
A fourth thing that you could say to someone who's been gone for a while is it wasn't the same without you or things weren't the same around here while you were gone.
And this really communicates to someone that it was noticeable that they were gone for a while, that things just weren't the same.
You missed them because they weren't there at the supper table or you missed them because they weren't working alongside you.
So to say to someone it wasn't the same with you gone or things weren't the same while you were gone really communicates to them that that they were missed.
In the last video I looked at the phrase it's good to see you and there's a variation on this where you can say it's really nice to see you.
I'm not sure if it's really nice to see these cats.
The cats are meowing because I think they want food.
It's almost their suppertime.
But another phrase, as you can say, it's really nice to see you, or it's really nice to see you again.
And that as well would be communicating to people how you feel that that inside you're feeling glad you're feeling happy to be able to see them.
And lastly, we'll go over a phrase that I went over in the other video.
In the other video I mentioned the phrase, how have you been?
So when you see someone and you're just curious about how their trip was, or you're just curious about what they've been up to while they were gone, you can say how have you been.
But the variation on that is a really quick way to say it.
You can say how you've been.
So we actually skip a word, we don't even say have, like we just say how you've been.
So it's how have you been?
But we actually say how you've been.
And some of you might be wondering why I pronounce the word been as been and not been.
We don't often in English say been, how have you been?
I think in the other video I overpronounce that.
Often in Canadian English we actually say been.
How have have you been or how you been.
Anyways, that's five more ways to greet someone that you haven't seen for a while.
I really missed all of you guys.
So leave a comment below if you've done that before or even if you haven't.
Give me a thumbs up.
Don't forget to subscribe if you're new here.
I'm Bob the Canadian.
You can learn English with Bob the Canadian.
I'm back back for a number of months again.
And let's just look forward to a new video every Tuesday.
and I'll be doing a live stream Friday morning again.
Look for some more information about that towards the end of the week, but I'm back.
It's fun to be back.
If you're wondering why I was gone, it's just a busy time at work.
The school where I teach is a semester school.
That means the students learn from September until the end of January, and then they write their exams.
And then their second semester goes from February 1st until the end of June.
So as we move from the first semester to the second semester, it's a lot of work for teachers.
So I just thought I would set aside making videos for a bit.
I hope you were able to keep learning while I was busy.
I'm sure you were, but it's really fun to be back and I look forward to doing a lot more of these.
Anyways, Bob the Canadian here.
Learn English with Bob the Canadian.
Have a great day.